If the question is:
How do we differentiate between the use of behavioral therapy / psychotherapy and drug therapy in depression?
Well, first let's not underestimate the benefit of medical intervention (drug)
Depression is catastrophic. He is responsible for very high suicide rates.
It also exhausts people and their families and is therefore very destructive as physical
Therefore, if you are in severe depression
You can try antidepressants, you will know within a month if they benefit you
If they help you maybe they will help you to not cut your life
For example, we can say that you are depressed because your life is distracted
Sometimes people are depressed even though their lives are only ...
Not so good, because no one has a perfect life, everyone has his own suffering
However, sometimes the lives of some people go as well as you might expect from anyone
Have friends, have intimate relationships ...
... they have a job they love, they are competitive, able to work ...
... work hard in their business
Do not fool themselves
Yet they are terribly depressed!
Sometimes antidepressants can fix it. So, Merry!
In the end, you are a living being, if there is something that will help you become stronger
To continue in life is great!
Did you know ... they say "everyone is taking antidepressants"
But in fact, no one takes these things without thinking
Half the time I spend with my depressed clients usually takes two years to convince them to try antidepressants.
Because they feel guilty about relying on external extortion to continue their lives,
That is what they can not afford!
But I say to them: "Well, if I had diabetes, would you refuse to take insulin?"
You were under pressure and exploded from the weakest point
This is what happens when you are under pressure, if there is something that can help you,
Try it, God's right! You will know within a month!
Or just stop if it does not work!
To mention this, you want to analyze it in several ways
do you have friends?
Do you have an intimate relationship or are seeking one?
Do you have a reasonable job? Have you received education suited to your level of intelligence?
Do you have something useful to make it out of business?
Do you have problems with drug or alcohol addiction?
Are there other behavioral problems such as irregular sleep or eating, which is a problem?
You want to differentiate all this and try to intervene to change behavior as much as possible
But sometimes they deal with people whose lives are so shattered that they do not know where to start!
They are different from those who regularly walk their lives
"Well, try this, maybe you will not commit suicide next month!"
Because if you die, it's hard to work with you!
Therefore, medical intervention or other ... When you are sick, do anything that makes you improve.
Leave your pride behind your back if necessary.
All this has nothing to do with behavioral intervention.
You want to face the problem by all available means.
But some antidepressants, especially for people whose lives go well but are depressed,
Antidepressants can make miracles!
Therefore, when the medical evidence in your favor is not specified
This is partly because the diagnosis of depression itself does not have a well-defined definition
They are two very different things that a person's life is exhilarating and that the person is depressed!
Antidepressants can not help much if a person's life is ominous.
If ... yes!